[Music
] Héctor Mejía greets you with the headlines
for today, Friday, November 20, there
is a worrying advance in the
state of Nevada after registering the
highest number of coronavirus cases in a
single day since the pandemic began
on Thursday, the state reported  more than 2400
cases and 6 more deaths the number of
hospitalizations also continues to
climb but this is due to an increase
in cases in the northern region of the state
while here in clark county
hospitalizations continue to be
registered at less than the highest
number in the past  August
and for his part, the governor says
he is receiving advice on
possible new regulations to
encourage the spread of coronaviruses
State officials say that Nevada
is exceeding the number of new cases
that those registered by the
states of Arizona and California are
anticipating  that the governor announces
new measures soon the city of
las vegas loses another event due to the
pandemic  organizers of the
mestre olympia professional bodybuilding competition have decided to move the
event to florida the show was
scheduled to take place at the
planet hollywood hotel next month
however the state of nevada limits
gatherings to 250 people while
the state of florida does not  they have that
limit event officials said
they will make a decision in the
next few weeks on the location of the
event for next year there are
enough signatures for
two initiatives that would increase
taxes for education in the state
the first proposal seeks to increase
taxes on the stands  high income
generated by gambling the second
includes an increase of one and a
half percentage to sales throughout the state the
teachers union calculates that if
approved the increase in taxes
would generate more than a billion dollars
a year now the proposals of  law are
addressed to legislators if they decide
not to vote  tar in the proposal the initiative
can go to the voters in the year
2022 and now we go to the
weather forecast more clouds during the day with
temperatures a little cooler in
the 70s today Friday the clouds should
clear tonight and then an end
Sunny week
I am Héctor Mejía and this was your brief
informative edition in Spanish
[Music]